hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
I was in New York this morning for a
Motorola event for the new flagship
smartphones so these are my quick first
impressions of them as I got to spend a
little bit of time with them and they're
actually really interesting smartphones
so the main new device you need to know
about is the Moto X style 2015 it's a
refreshed Moto X for this year and there
really wasn't a whole lot like wrong
with last year's Moto X but there are
plenty of changes for this one it's like
the Nexus 6 and the 2014 Moto X got
together had a baby and then attached a
piece of metal to the back of it I don't
know that's all I got but really this
new Moto X reminds me a lot of the Nexus
6 in the hand in a lot of ways and I use
the Nexus 6 for months so in the hander
really does feel similar and familiar
with the big 5.7 inch quad HD display
and a slightly curved glass at the edges
and the big curbs sloping back it just
screams Nexus 6 to me you can change the
material of the back of course through
moto maker and there will be plenty of
choices and you will also be able to
change the color of that metal strip in
the center so you can get just the right
accent color for your look and that bump
on the back yes there's a little dimple
it returns for the Moto X every Moto X
has had a sort of awesome dimple so I'm
glad to see that one there and the Moto
X has on paper pretty killer specs all
right I'd ready you're sitting down have
a listen to this list okay snapdragon
808 6 core chip inside which has had no
problems in any other devices three
gigabytes of RAM 64 gigabytes of storage
plus an optional microSD card slot for
up to 128 more gigabytes a three
thousand milliamp hour battery fit
inside this curved back super fast turbo
charging which they claimed is the
fastest in any phone give you something
like 10 hours of charge in 15 minutes
plugged in a 5.7 inch quad HD LCD
display which is about 520 pixels per
inch and it's big but with really thin
bezels so the whole phone should fit in
the same footprint as something like an
iPhone 6 plus so it's not insanely huge
stereo front-facing speakers
unlike the single one on the last year's
Moto X so magnificent loud crispy audio
and watching videos listening to music
gaming all that a brand new totally
revamped 21 megapixel camera on the back
with a
- aperture dual LED flash and of course
capable of shooting some crispy 4k video
throw a NATO 2.11 AC Wi-Fi Bluetooth 4.1
and yes it has NFC looking at you one +
and all the hardware here is paired with
an ear stock Android experience in the
software so it's tailored to give a few
improvements here and there to add
function but also allow for quick
updates so hopefully this one will be
getting Android M pretty early and so I
mean all this is really classic Motorola
on one hand you know not really
surprised that this lineup is so solid
all starting at just $399 that is a
super competitive price but at the same
time you got to hand it to them like
it's a pretty incredible thing looking
at something like this I think it's
something I definitely want in my pocket
now just seeing the numbers on paper is
nice that's one thing but I do still
have some concerns naturally obviously
number one that camera it's no secret
that Motorola has struggled with the
camera and their flagships in past years
they've made improvements obviously but
it's I'm not sure anyone would go out
and say you know the Moto X or the Droid
turbo is anywhere near as good as the
top flagship smartphone cameras out here
now so Motorola claims that this new
camera is a whole new ballgame and that
this you know early reviews from DX Oh
mark put it in the top three of all
smartphone cameras well I read that
review and I'll link in the description
if you want to also and I played with it
in person here at the event gazing at
its 21 megapixels of glory and I'm still
not totally convinced obviously it's a
make-or-break feature for a lot of
people so once I get to spend a lot more
time with this phone the camera is
definitely something I'm going to have
to spend a lot of time with and
thoroughly test also up front is a 5
megapixel wide-angle selfie camera and
yes that's a front-facing flash another
concern for me on this phone is the size
the phone has gotten a lot bigger it
definitely feels bigger in pretty much
every way in the hand than the old Moto
X in fact I wish I had the first gen
Moto X here to show you just how much
this phone has blown up in size over the
years it used to be focused on being
small this is the first moto X that
actually to me feels like it's going to
be a two-handed device for a lot of
people versus one hand it's going to
look huge in a store next to a galaxy s6
or even an LG g4 but you know what past
that I'm pretty pumped for when this
thing
comes out in September it's a
competitively priced obviously really
good-looking phone in a lot of ways so
it'll get some attention and I'm always
a fan of the near stock Android feel it
always seems to have the you know
buttery smooth performance and also moto
assist and moto gestures are still there
and still useful you can actually now
you can double chop the phone to get the
LED light to light up for a flashlight
and of course there's the always
reliable double twist to open the camera
app and a whole bunch of stuff like that
much much more all these useful features
from the last Moto X can be turned on
for viewing notifications getting
automatic voice assistance etc stuff
like that also there's been a little bit
of confusion about the versions of this
phone that exists so if you or anyone
you know is confused about that go ahead
and link them to this point in the video
all right ready
we have three phones the Moto X style
the Moto X pure edition and the Moto X
play the Moto X style is a flagship
coming to the US that we just talked
about looks great the Moto X pure
edition is the same thing but unlocked
no-contract and sold directly to the
consumer and that works with LTE bands
from basically every carrier so nothing
really pier or different about that
experience just no carrier's involved
pop a SIM card in and go same price and
then the Moto X play is actually a
different phone that's never coming to
the US but it'll cost $100 less have a
smaller 5.5 inch 1080p display
Snapdragon 615 two gigs of ram and a
huge 3630 milliamp hour battery would
have loved to see this huge battery and
some other phones but it is what it is
so there you have it these are my
impressions of Motorola's new hardware
feel free to leave a thumbs up if you
enjoyed and see if you can guess what
camera this video was shot on thanks for
watching guys touching the next one bass
you